we got these chairs geez I've never
taken a Latin class in my life bring it
on I mean I would say eka ala quando 0
room we are all room it's a V yeah but I
think that they do the visas like W sin
alpha bats
[Music]
I think alphabets escaped him you and
just I feel like that sounds very Latin
that sounds like the name of a Roman
gladiator it's true it also has way too
many vowels yeah calm now it's vowels
land Oh weird to Dennis that's the
beauty one there's no cartoon in English
Audrey's beauty but it sounds like
ugliness I think that's why I fell out
of favor pretty sure it's in private
okay
infamous apprentice in private
[Music]
the correct pronunciation of this word
is a little tricky actually if you asked
someone conversant with Latin in the
16th or the 17th century how to
pronounce this word they would say in
Primus have you asked an ancient Roman
in the 1st century BC he would say in
preemies the word in Primus means in the
first place or among the first things if
you want to understand something you
almost always have to go back to its
source
or to its roots whether you're thinking
about the etymological roots of a word
like in Primus or the roots of much
bigger and more important things ideas
in history literature art philosophy or
what have you
[Music]